téva 20h avec dominique baudis crise de
l'énergie les pays industrialisés n'en
sont pas les seules victimes elle
aggrave aussi la situation des pays du
tiers-monde le cnpf et l'énergie
l'industrie française devra économiser
14 millions de tonnes de pétrole d'ici à
1985 aînés paquet présente le bilan de
son action de médiateur au président la
république dans ce journal
un exemple concret des contacts souvent
difficiles entre administration et
administrés
san salvador les 11 otages l'ambassade
de france toujours prisonnier le
président du panama en visite en france
propose sa médiation
bonsoir le chômage la hausse des prix
l'énergie chère en un mot la crise tout
cela nous le retrouvons quotidiennement
dans l'actualité aidant nos
préoccupations en france en europe aux
états unis à tel point que l'on finit
parfois par s'imaginer qu'il s'agit d'un
phénomène que nous serions les seuls à
subir nous autres pays industrialisés
or il faut savoir que cette crise frappe
également les pays du tiers-monde est
allé frappe d'autant plus sévèrement
qu'elle vient s'ajouter à tous les
autres phénomènes structurels qui pèsent
sur ces pays
l'analphabétisme la malnutrition la
croissance démographique un contrôle et
la mortalité infantile et la liste ces
fléaux est encore longue
la crise donc est venu aggraver la
situation de ces pays du tiers-monde
d'autant plus que dans cette conjoncture
défavorable les pays industrialisés
retrouve les vieux réflexes
d'autodéfense l'aide occidentale a
diminué le protectionnisme a retrouvé
ses droits
l'endettement des pays pauvres c'est
donc alourdi alors ces sujets de
préoccupations seront autant de sujets
de réflexion à l'occasion d'un vaste
carrefour la cnuced traduisait la
conférence des nations unies sur le
commerce et le développement
159 pays vont participer à cette
conférence de manille dont les travaux
commencent aujourd'hui
cela représente 3 milliards d'hommes et
de femmes les trois quarts de l'humanité
et à la veille de l'ouverture de cette
conférence de la cnuced 12 pays
industrialisés parmi lesquels là
ans ont décidé de faire un geste de
bonne volonté ils ont annulé les dettes
que devait leur payer les pays les plus
pauvres de la planète
emmanuel de la taille du tiers-monde se
sont encore aggravées
l'occident ne leur prêtent pas assez de
dollars ils sont écrasés de dette avec
notre inflation il peine au produit de
plus en plus cher et nous accusent de
sous payer les leurs ou de leur fermer
nos marchés pour endiguer notre chômage
voyons les points essentiels de ces
inégalités accablante
primo alors que le tiers monde
représente les trois quarts de la
population mondiale il n'en reçoit que
le cinquième des ressources
si dans le marché commun le revenu moyen
par habitant tourne autour de 2500
francs par mois la majorité des
habitants du tiers monde ont moins de
2000 francs par an des quarante pays
moins de 80 francs par mois
exemple la plupart des pays africains ou
l'inde sans compter la chine dépourvue
de statistiques
secundo les nouveaux rivaux industriels
qui nous font peur fournissent moins de
10% de la production mondiale au plus 1%
l'an 2000 en combinant comme le japon le
capitalisme et leurs traditions
surgissent de l'asie au mexique
les concurrents qui nous menacent avec
de bons produits à bas salaires il nous
reproche notre protectionnisme
et pourtant le commissariat au plan a
calculé que leur compétition a engendré
chez nous un surplus l'emploi et c'est
avec le tiers-monde que la france
réalise ses meilleures sur plus de
devises
tertio le tiers-monde vite encore
essentiellement sur une agriculture qui
ne lui rapporte pas assez mal fait la
hausse des matières premières les pays
pauvres réclament toujours un système de
stabilisation des prix qui l'aurait par
n'y aurait des baies souvent ruineuse
enfin de déséquilibre s'accroît entre
les prêts et les bêtes
avec la crise les pays riches ont
largement réduit leur aide au dessous de
0 7% de leur produit national
la france met les autres 0 6% et le
tiers monde s'enfonce dans le cercle
vicieux d'un endettement pharamineux 15
100 milliards de francs un an de toute
notre consommation
les remises de dettes décidé par douze
pays dont la france ne représente que 2%
de ce fardeau démesurée avec la chine
qui se lance dans la course au
développement tandis que tant de pays ne
réussissent pas à sortir de la misère
notre avenir sur 20 ans se jouera
largement sur la capacité de l'occident
à
résoudre le conflit qui oppose une
minorité de riches au nord et une
multitude de pau au sud de la planète
lorsque l'on parle de millions de tonnes
de pétrole ou de millions de barils de
pétrole
on a parfois du mal à imaginer ce que là
ce que cela représente exactement
par exemple les économies d'énergie
réalisées l'an dernier par les français
16 millions de tonnes de pétrole
et bien cela représente 75 fois la
cargaison de l'amoco cadiz
alors à qui doit-on cette économie de 16
millions de tonnes de pétrole pour
moitié à nous-mêmes à nous tous
ce sont des économies réalisées par les
particuliers les consommateurs quant aux
industriels ils ont contribué à ces
économies dans la proportion de 20%
cet effort peut-être et va être
développé c'est d'ailleurs l'objet d'un
colloque organisé par le cnpf
cela suppose des investissements
supplémentaires
les industriels consacré l'année
dernière 1 milliard de francs aux
économies d'énergie
certains considèrent qu'il faudrait
atteindre 3 milliards de francs par an
on le voit dans ce domaine les économies
coûte cher
une enquête de michel chevalet nous
disposons en france d'une source
inépuisable d'énergie
ce n'est pas le charbon encore moins le
pétrole et le nucléaire
ce sont les économies d'énergie et oui à
l'horizon 85 alors que le nucléaire doit
nous faire économiser 40 2 millions de
tonnes d'équivalent pétrole
les économies d'énergie arriveront
presque au même bilan
or jusqu'à présent ces économies
d'énergie ont été avant tout le fait des
particuliers 15 millions de tonnes
d'équivalent pétrole ont été ainsi
économisés chaque année 15 millions de
tonnes d'équivalent pétrole cela
représente tout de même 75 amoco cadiz
aujourd'hui c'est vers les industriels
que se tourne le gouvernement et plus
précisément le patronat le cnpf
l'industrie qui consomme un tiers de
notre énergie devra d'ici 1980 faire
encore plus facile à dire car cela
nécessite d'abord une volonté
ensuite une remise en cause de procédés
de fabrication ainsi à péchiney dans
l'aluminium détient aujourd'hui le
record mondial d'économie de
kilowattheures
citons également les cimenteries qui ont
réussi le tour de force d'économiser 25
% d'énergie tout en réduisant leur
pollution
mais les économies d'énergie exige un
investissement
chaque tonne de pétrole économisée
nécessite en effet deux mille francs et
dc 1985 estime l'agent ce pour les
économies d'énergie c'est chaque année 3
milliards de francs qui seront consacrés
à ce secteur
en somme d'une pierre on va faire deux
coups puisque l'on va créer chaque année
vingt mille emplois nouveaux et
maintenant comme chaque soir le point de
la campagne électorale en france et en
europe avec ce journal des européennes
préparer ce soir par jacques hébert et
patrice duhamel
et
alain peyrefitte à strasbourg l'europe
ne peut progresser que par l'exercice en
commun des souverainetés nationales le
garde des sceaux parlait devant le
conseil de l'europe
certains pionniers avaient conçu
l'espoir qui n'était pas dénué de
générosité ni de grandeur qu'une
intégration supranationale provoquerait
le dépérissement des états des
gouvernements nationaux des parlements
nationaux au profit d'institutions
indépendantes de ces états et supérieur
elle l'expérience de ses 30 ans a montré
que cette visée ne tenait pas compte des
réalités nos vieilles nations forgée par
les siècles ne peuvent pas s'effacer
comme pur le faire les treize jeunes
états d'amérique
comme disait familièrement le général de
gaulle on ne fait pas d'omelette avec
des oeufs durs michel pinton délégué
général de l'udf jean lecanuet
n'appartient pas à la secte des supra
nationaux comme le déclare jacques
chirac
le jeu qui consiste à opposer
déclarations passées et présentes et
plein de péril jacques chirac et
angoulême les centristes restent les
centristes parler de convergence dans la
majorité c'est créer la confusion et
obscurcir le débat le communiste maxime
gremetz sur les dernières déclarations
de pierre mauroy au club de la presse
c'est une nouvelle confirmation de
l'identité de vues qui prévaut entre le
parti socialiste et l'udf sur les
questions européennes
en clair pierre mauroy s'assoit sur les
genoux de jean lecanuet en marge de la
campagne du dit jeu à jean françois
poncet a décidé d'expliquer et de rendre
plus accessible le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes avant le
conseil des ministres des affaires
étrangères demain à bruxelles jean
françois poncet a pris l'initiative
d'une réunion préparatoire
portes ouvertes aujourd'hui au quai
d'orsay gérard saint paul et messieurs
nous sommes réunis pour préparer comme
nous le faisons
une fois par mois avant la réunion du
conseil des ministres à bruxelles les
différents points qui seront inscrits à
l'ordre du jour et dont nous aurons à
parler d'honneur aux communautés
européennes c'est la première fois
qu'une réunion de ce genre est filmé par
la télévision mais je pense que c'est un
sujet qui est de nature à intéresser
tous les français qui est celui de
savoir comment la france est
effectivement représenté à bruxelles
comment ces intérêts ils sont défendre
et bien nous avons une réunion du
conseil des ministres
tous les mois à bruxelles c'est là que
les points de vue de la france sont
exposées
cette réunion elle est préparée la
veille par une réunion des principaux
fonctionnaires avec le secrétaire d'état
aux affaires étrangères plus
particulièrement chargé des affaires
européennes c'est au cours de cette
réunion que les positions de la france
sont définitivement arrête alors à
l'ordre du jour de notre réunion à
bruxelles de demain 8 mai nous avons un
certain nombre de questions importantes
la principale est celle du
renouvellement de l'accord qui lie les
neuf pays de la communauté
cinquante six états africains pacifique
et caraïbes
c'est ce qu'on appelle la corde lomé un
peut-être un esquimau élu député
européen le danemark en effet décidé de
réserver un siège pour le groenland qui
vient d'accéder à l'autonomie
la bataille se jouera entre centristes
ya social-démocrate groenlandais les
élections européennes sur tf1 jeudi 17
mai à 20h30 face à face jacques chirac
georges marchais françois mitterrand et
simone veil
un face-à-face diffusée en direct sur
tf1 et rtl et animé par chris o'meara
date rédacteur en chef de tf1 et
alexandre balou directeur adjoint de la
rédaction de rtl vendredi 18 mai à 20h30
face à face michel debré rpr pierre
mauroy parti socialiste vendredi 25 mai
à 20h30 face à face jean françois deniau
udf charles fiterman parti communiste
enfin dans nos éditions de 13 heures et
après tirage au sort sont invités le 21
mai georges marchais le 22 mai jacques
chirac le 23 mai françois mitterrand et
le 25 mai simone veil
et
la suite de l'actualité la situation est
toujours dans l'impasse à san salvador
les membres des commandos retiennent
toujours en otage aux personnes parmi
lesquelles vous le savez l'ambassadeur
de france le gouvernement du salvador
affirme qu'il ne négociera pas mais
déclare aussi qu'il ne recourra pas à la
force alors l'issue de cette affaire est
difficile à prévoir un espoir toutefois
le président du panama qui se trouve
aujourd'hui en visite en france propose
une médiation
le président giscard d'estaing a
accueilli favorablement cette
proposition tentaculaire cafta
kafkaïenne inhumaine
ubuesque tout a été dit sur certains
travers de l'administration sur le
cynisme dont elle peut faire preuve
parfois sur ces règlements impénétrable
sur ces lenteurs aux conséquences
souvent incalculables et face à ce que
les français considèrent souvent comme
une sorte de monstre froid une
institution et un homme
le médiateur en effet pour fonction de
s'interposer entre l'administration et
les administrés
lorsqu'il est saisi de situation
particulièrement inacceptable cette
fonction de mes dates de médiateurs
créés il y a 6 ans est exercée depuis
cinq ans par monsieur henné kpémé paquet
et comme chaque année il a présenté un
rapport faisant le bilan de son action
ce rapport a été remis ce matin au
président de la république et cet après
midi au premier ministre cette année le
médiateur est intervenue plus de sept
mille fois et derrière ce chiffre
autant de situations particulières
toujours exaspérante souvent douloureuse
avec ce reportage de marie geneviève
lemoine
un exemple concret celui de deux
personnes âgées dans la vieillesse
aurait pu devenir un véritable enfer en
1962 énergie gilbert prend sa retraite
et se retire à la campagne ap rideau
dans son village natal
il possède un terrain sur lequel il veut
bâtir sa maison mais le permis de
construire lui est refusée par la
direction départementale de l'équipement
motif le projet de déviation
autoroutière de la rn10 interdit toute
construction à cet endroit
les services de l'équipement concept
alors à monsieur gilbert d'acquérir un
autre terrain réputé particulièrement
paisible
de l'autre côté du village une
obligation j'étais obligé de l'acheter
si je voulais bâtir un pays dow alors
grassement à l'api rideau était mort
pour
je ne pouvais rien fait robin part et
vous vouliez venir à périseaux pourquoi
ben je suis né il ya 66 ans ici cette
maison vous voyez derrière j'étais même
des attaches je suis du monde encore
quitte ici qui m'ont vu gamins et pusan
est la venue l'avenue paris si on
revient à ses premiers amours en 1964 le
permis de construire est accordé à peine
la maison terminée
le projet initial de la déviation est
abandonné pour un nouveau tracé à quatre
voies qui passent justement à 50 mètres
au dessous de la propriété c'est le
début d'un conflit entre monsieur
gilbert et l'administration qui durera
15 ans angers tout ça quand j'étais
militaire de s'enlever
meubles vous savez c'est pour ça qu'il
voulait me retirer à la campagne pour
être tranquille et vivre elle peut
vraiment le market en profiter
malheureusement avec une croissance et
l'enfer bon mari faisait la sieste dans
le jardin ils peuvent plus faire la
sieste l'après midi de danse opéra les
jours de pointe ou trafic atteint 30
mille véhicules dans 25 % ce sont des
camions l'administration qui reconnaît
sa responsabilité a proposé plusieurs
solutions
l'isolation phonique de la maison une
buttes antibruit ou un rideau d'arbres
ces palliatifs toujours insuffisant ne
sont pas tous réalisés la commune de
ruffec achète alors un terrain en
contrebas de la maison pour faire un
remblai vous est pas la dde d'acheter ce
copain excusé pour faire bien je pense
que si c'est parce que si c'est la
raison pour laquelle je lui demanderais
oublier que vous entendez
pour la raison pour laquelle je lui
rendrai que d'indemniser la commune
participer aux frais qui ont été
entraînés pour la ville de ruffec
aujourd'hui grâce à l'intervention du
médiateur et mes paquets
l'administration va réparer son erreur
le ministère des transports propose à
monsieur madame gilbert de racheter la
maison ou de leur donner une indemnité
pour préjudice qu'ils estiment à 120 me
sens beaucoup vous voyez partout mais
j'ai fait je sais ces plantations
d'arbres je suis attaché maintenant ici
comment on peut partir maintenant vous
recommencez sujet fait depuis 15 ans je
ne sois plus la force d'ailleurs aller
où maintenant locaux des déviations pour
garnir notre hôte appel ou un terrain
d'opération ou n'importe quoi
franchement on est tranquille quoi pour
ça qu'on a décidé de rester ici
en matière sociale cette semaine qui
commence sera dominée par le 38ème
congrès de la cfdt de mende 1800
délégués se retrouveront à brest pour
ces assises dont la clôture ne sera
prononcée que samedi prochain car ce
congrès de la confédération française
démocratique du travail
plus de 3000 syndicats seront
représentés alors on connaît le rôle des
syndicats
en revanche on connaît moins la façon
dont ces organisations fonctionnent quel
est l'avis de leur cellule de base
on connaît également le visage de leurs
dirigeants on connaît moins le profil de
leurs militants pour mieux comprendre ce
qu est un syndicat est ce que sont ces
militants ce reportage de françois baud
il a réalisé son enquête dans un groupe
d'assurances employant 12 mille six
cents salariés sur les douze mille six
cents salariés qui travaillent aux
assurances générales de france
3200 sont syndiqués et 1200 leur carte
cfd et voilà l'homme clé du syndicat le
collecteur de cotisation car sans
ressources financières à l'activité
syndicale pas d'adhérents et pas de
syndicat et quel est le taux de
cotisation au ca s'échelonnent entre ces
gares chizé entre 20 et 75 francs par
mois
de préparer l'ordre du jour de la rue
vendredi
chaque semaine la section syndicale
serait elle représente le noyau du
syndicat son état major
je regroupe ainsi que recueille un
trésorier
les délégués du personnel les délégués
au comité d'entreprise
les délégués syndicaux fonctionnement en
collectif c'est-à-dire paris province
dont quatre sections paris et 43 en
province qui elle mène sont reliés aux
syndicats d assurance de leur localité
qui ensuite est relié la fédération des
services c'est-à-dire professionnels qui
elle-même est relié à la confédération
en france tout centrales syndicales
réunies on compte 55 me section
syndicale à la situation actuelle des
travailleurs à savoir que c'est une
réponse à l'informatisation de la
filiation sociale qui représente ses
adhérents de la direction qui défend les
revendications des salariés qui
participent aux négociations et tout
cela entraîne parfois des cons pour
pouvoir dans l'entreprise avoir une
négociation qui a commencé il ya un mois
il a fallu les des actions dans toute la
profession en particulier en assurance
au début du trimestre
sans action il n'y a pas de négociation
c'est le fondement même de toute la
lutte sociale et syndicale
vous vous demandiez comment êtes vous
devenue militante parce que j'ai envie
de battre on ne vient pas comme ça on y
vient comment
quand on a des problèmes dans un service
incontournable quand on voit la vie que
le que l'on mène la vie quotidienne je
pense et puis un jour on sent que joe
s'enclenche certainement vous rappelez
pas vous quand ça s'est produit
j'étais dans un secteur aussi favorable
aux syndicats je pense que c'est ça
aussi
j'avais fait d'une j'ai une vision du
monde qui ne l'est pas et flore et peut
être au départ et vous regrettez rien
que nous pour du tout au contraire notre
profession vient de perdre l'une de ses
plus grandes signatures
pierre viansson-ponté est mort la nuit
dernière à paris il était âgé de 58 ans
l'éditorialiste du monde avait commencé
sa carrière de journaliste à l' agence
france-presse
atteint depuis plusieurs mois par la
maladie il avait évoqué son mal dans un
livre écrit en collaboration avec le
professeur choir john baird sous le
titre changer la mort pierre
viansson-ponté était alité mais il n'en
continue pas moins à écrire sont gagnées
papier été publiés samedi
c'était sa dernière chronique au fil de
la semaine pour le supplément
hebdomadaire du monde dont il avait la
charge
clément de quatre pages il publiait
chaque semaine une chronique qui
s'appelait au fil une chronique à fait
remarquable de bois parce que pendant
sept ans il ne l'a pas interrompu un
jour et samedi dernier alors qu'il
souffrait atrocement depuis plusieurs
mois il a tenu à remettre sa chronique
hebdomadaire et cette chronique et
c'était un peu ce que j'appellerais la
chronique de l'air du temps et ne
parlent pas et loin de l'arc de
politique nous nous sommes parfois
saturé mais il parlait de la vie
intellectuelle de la vie de tous les
jours
alors ce que j'admirais beaucoup en lui
d'une part certaines facilités
extraordinaire des tricks
il écrivait vite et bien sans rappeler
j'ai toujours été jaloux de lui sur ce
plan là et puis il a donné un ton il
avait un ton et notamment dans pour
traiter vos clés du problème délicat
difficile grieder tous deux blessés et
trouver le ton juste
il le trouvait tout de suite et en
dehors de cette chronique où il
s'exprimait d'une liberté totale sur
tous les sujets qu'ils venaient à
l'esprit il publier des éditoriaux de
temps à autre monde
et précisément sur les problèmes
délicats des problèmes demeurent de
justice il était vraiment non seulement
à l'honneur de la presse française mais
il était pour nous d'un prix
exceptionnels il apporte une
contribution que le regretteront
longtemps encore réaction du premier
ministre monsieur raymond barre a
déclaré j'ai appris la mort de monsieur
viansson-ponté avec beaucoup de
tristesse était un grand journaliste
un homme de grande culture est un homme
de caractère je voudrais saluer sa
mémoire à votre compagnie jean claude
narcy la suite de la qualité mais
d'abord 11 blessés dont deux graves dans
un accident de voiture spectaculaire cet
après-midi boulevard haussmann à paris
un taxi est monté sur le trottoir devant
une entrée les galeries lafayette le
véhicule a fauché la foule des badauds
et des clients il a ensuite renversé une
cabine téléphonique occupé par un jeune
homme d'après les premières
constatations c'est à la suite d'une
défaillance technique que le taxi est
monté sur le trottoir et le chauffeur
aurait également été victime d'un
malaise
les 33 attentats commis la nuit dernière
en corse n'ont toujours pas été
revendiqué ces explosions ont fait des
dégâts importants mais pas de victime je
vous le rappelle ajaccio l'explosion de
noves bombe a partiellement détruit des
agences immobilières des cabinets
d'assurances les autres objectifs ont
été des villages de vacances ou des
terrains de camping à bastia enfin une
charge de dynamite a été désamorcée
avait été déplacée devant les services
de l'équipement
ce matin le conseil régional qui avait
déclaré que l'état n'assurerait pas
l'ordre et la sécurité dans l'île s'est
vu répondre par le préfet de région que
le gouvernement ne pratiquera pas la
répression pour la répression il dit
amin dada ne se rendra pas à fès le
secrétaire général adjoint de la
conférence islamique a démenti ce matin
les rumeurs selon lesquelles l'ancien
président ougandais se rendrait au maroc
pour participer aux travaux de cette
conférence islamique selon le
daily telegraph idi amin dada se
trouverait actuellement en libye par
ailleurs la commission préparatoire à la
conférence a suspendu la participation
égyptienne cela la demande de plusieurs
délégations
c'est demain que s'ouvre la conférence
qui va réunir quelques 3000 délégués au
liban l'aviation israélienne a bombardé
des concentrations fedayin palestiniens
au nord de métaux là on ne connaît pas
le nombre des victimes en revanche le
raid que les israéliens auraient
effectué près de tirs tuant onze
personnes a été démentie par les
correspondants étrangers en poste ont
libre
l'attentât dans lequel l'ancien
directeur de la sécurité générale
espagnole monsieur emilio rodriguez
romane a été grièvement blessé ce matin
à madrid fait suite à une série
d'actions qui a fait 52 morts en espagne
depuis le début de l'année les attentats
sont surtout localisé au pays basque où
ils sont revendiqués en général par
l'été a ainsi qu'à barcelone et madrid
zone d'action des grapo l'attentât de ce
matin a eu lieu en plein centre de
madrid
monsieur rodriguez romain a été abattu
devant son domicile où elle avait vu
alors qu'il s'apprêtait à monter en
voiture en compagnie de son fils de 7
ans un commando de deux personnes a fait
feu à bout portant sur lui le blessant
grièvement à la tête avant de prendre la
fuite en france à usinor longwy des
ouvriers sidérurgistes occupe depuis cet
après midi les locaux de la direction
alexandre sanguinetti s'est vu attribué
aujourd'hui le prix du mémorial pour son
livre histoire du soldat de la violence
et des pouvoirs édité chez ramsay ce
prix littéraire été créé par la ville
d'ajaccio pour récompenser une oeuvre
conforme aux vertus que défend des
napoléon bonaparte
air france se change de porcs rouges
dans les premières classes bleu pour le
les classes ce touriste les tissus des
fauteuils sont aux chiffres de la
compagnie nationale la moquette est
uniformément bleu foncé ces nouvelles
armes ni ses nouvelles couleurs
harmonieuses faisant jouer entre elles
les trois couleurs nationales je pensais
qu'on verrait la photo mais elle ne
vient pas et tout cela donne une
impression à la fois sobre et
chaleureuse espace vous la verrez dans
notre prochain journal c'est le football
qui a été le grand perdant de la
rencontre avignon montpellier match
remporté par avignon 1 0 à montpellier
des bagarres inqualifiable entre joueurs
d'une part mais aussi des bannières dans
les tribunes larbitre lui-même a dû être
conduit sous bonne escorte dans les
vestiaires avant de s'esquiver protégé
par la police
journalistes ont même été frappé et sans
raison par des joueurs au paroxysme de
l'excitation joueur énervé par les
décisions de larbitre vraiment le
spectacle était affligeant à montpellier
regarder
il faut espérer que ce sera plus calme
pour la finale de la coupe de france en
effet monsieur giscard d'estaing
présidera en personne cette finale de la
coupe le 16 juin prochain au parc des
princes la première étape de grande
montagne du tour d'espagne cycliste a
été fatal au français levasseur qui a
perdu la première place au classement
général au profit de deux autos melk le
landais et quatrième de cette étape
remportée par l'espagnol angel lopez
d'al alam
si les températures sont toujours
fraîches pour la saison elles deviennent
cependant plus acceptable sur l'ensemble
du pays aujourd'hui en début d'après
midi le thermomètre varier d'une région
à l'autre de 10 à 18 degrés et puis
demain
eh bien demain le temps sera couvert
avec quelques pluies sur les régions
voisines de la mer du nord et de la
manche en revanche sur la plus grande
partie de la france le temps sera
ensoleillé
les températures plus élevées toutefois
au fil de la journée des nuages se
feront plus abondants près des pyrénées
où des orages isolés pourraient éclater
le soir voilà ce journal est maintenant
terminée en fin de journée pour la
dernière édition de tf1 actualité vous
pourrez retrouver bruno masure merci de
votre attention
passer une bonne soirée